president Trump's temporary ban on
immigrants from seven Muslim majority
countries has been criticized as being
unamerican one of the people who was
detained over the weekend was a
five-year-old who has detained for hours
separated from his mother who's from
Iran but the ban is also having an
effect on American military strategy in
the Middle East instead of protecting
the u.s. Republican senators John McCain
and Lindsey Graham are warning that the
ban could be a self-inflicted wound in
the fight against terrorism
it was obviously washed out but no
effort was really made to consider what
the strategic impact was in any of those
seven countries this is Tony Cortez Minh
he writes and advises on military policy
not immigration
but quarters Minh sees Trump's executive
order as more than an immigration policy
well it already has a major effect on
isil's propaganda they picked up on
those immediately already some jihadist
groups are claiming victory over the
executive order saying that the policy
proves the United States is at war with
Islam they're calling president Trump's
action the Blessed banned the policy
played perfectly into Isis's most vital
narrative but the West persecuted
Muslims and that it is a holy duty to
fight back that message carries even
more weight when paired with the fact
that Trump has explicitly tailored the
ban to make it easier for Christians to
immigrate to the US it relates to
persecuted Christians do you see them as
kind of a priority here as I support you
to the ban is also rattling
relationships with key partners in the
Middle East and around the world it
tends to alienate laws ones even if
they're not in the southern countries
and people outside those countries now
have no idea of what's going to happen
next most of the world's Muslims are not
in the Middle East a substantial number
are in Africa but others are strategic
partners in Asia Indonesia India is a
country that has a very large number of
Muslims
Iraq is one strategic partner that is
bearing most of the
burden in the fight against Isis and has
lost thousands of soldiers along the way
it's a country that the US needs on its
side but Iraq is one of the countries
included in the ban and they're not
happy at the humiliating is that fitting
in the faith of Iraqis when you are
essentially fighting side by side with
Iraqi troops to ban all entry from Iraq
make no real sense at all it was an
almost perfect way of alienating a
partner in three other banned countries
Libya Somalia and Yemen the US has a
small military presence to monitor
terror groups and conduct counter-terror
operations and they impact the message
you are sending to all these countries
is that regardless of who they are I'll
actually cooperate with the United
States cluded the u.s. also counts on a
broader coalition of security allies for
intelligence sharing and other
counterterrorism operations every one of
these countries are muslim-majority
nations and many have spoken out against
the ban we heard from Pakistan's foreign
minister the move will not affect
terrorists however it will increase the
miseries of the victims of terrorism so
in many ways you've taken a threat which
gets an immense amount of media
attention but actually produces almost
no casualties and you used it in ways
which threaten our strategic
partnerships and military relations with
critical largely Muslim States roughly
from Morocco to Malaysia
the hasty release of the executive order
is also creating risks within Trump's
days-old national security team there is
a Secretary of Defense who has a great
deal of competence in this area and it's
focused some of our broader issues in
security particularly in the countries
that were named and he was not consulted
secretary mattis reportedly saw draft of
the executive order just hours before it
was signed Trump gave him no input this
may be because six months
earlier mattes said publicly that a
Muslim immigration band would quote send
shockwaves through the entire
international system and he was right
Trump's band didn't just affect the
people immigrating to the United States
from seven Muslim majority countries it
is having a much broader negative effect
on the security partnerships that the US
depends on in the Middle East in Asia a
network of relationships that is not
easily repaired
[Music]